Hi everyone, this
is Dr. Rio from
the Department of
Family Medicine.
Today's topic is going
to be the aging patient.
Our objectives by the
end of this session
is that you'll be able
to describe some of
the basic principles
of aging and how they
contribute to the
development of geriatric
syndromes that affect
patients overall
health and well-being,
describe some of the
effects of aging on
the human body, obtain
a history from a
geriatric patient, and be
able to complete a
geriatric assessment.
So what is geriatrics?
Basically, it's the
branch of medicine
that focuses on
the care of the
elderly, focuses on
prevention and care
of chronic illness,
and keeping people
independent for as
long as possible.
A geriatric patient
is someone who is 65
years of age or older,
and there's a subset
of this category that
we call the oldest
old, and those are
patients who are
80 years old or
older so something to
understand about the
geriatric population the
world's population
is aging at a rapid
rate this demographic
transition is
accompanied by an
epidemiologic transition what
we're observing is
that non-communicable
chronic diseases are
the major cause of
death and contributors
to the burden of
disease and disability
in our population
there's also
concomitant change in
dependency this is like
the ratio of adults
who are in the workforce
to those who are
typically out of the
workforce so for example
workforce would be
patients who are
you know 14 and older
who can work and
out of the workforce
would be infants,
children, the
retired, or the young
old, who are still
active but are not
working in paid work.
This dependency
and epidemiologic
transition causes a
ripple effect on things
like economic growth,
migration patterns,
patterns for work
and retirement,
family structures,
pension and health
systems, social
services, supports,
etc. There is a lot
that is dependent on
your population now
with this epidemiologic
change what we're talking
about in this effect
downstream is that we
know it will affect
health care and
societal programs for
example the rate of
natural increase of a
population depends on
birth and death rates so
and these are dependent
on or influenced by
our age structure births
typically occur in
people in the younger
adult-to-age groups,
and if there are
comparatively more young
adults than older
adults, then there will
be obviously more births
than deaths, which
means a population
that is able to sustain
itself and grow
accordingly. A population of
young adults needs
things like a sufficient
number of schools and
later on enough jobs
to accommodate them,
housing, food, etc.
Countries with a
larger proportion of
older patients or
people must develop
systems for retirement
as well as for
social services and
for medical care to
serve their needs.
They are dependent
sometimes on a greater
quantity of things.
So as our population
ages, our needs change
from child care in
schools to jobs and
housing to medical care
and other social support
systems. Now our
geriatric population
then means that they
are sharing a limited
number of resources
in our environment and
so we have to plan for
these accordingly and
what we're noticing is
that as our population
ages around the
world sometimes these
systems aren't in place
fast enough to help
support them so geriatric
population worldwide
when we look at the
world as a whole we
see that one in eight
people are 60 years old
or older at least
12 percent of people
worldwide fit this
demographic so that's about a
little over 600 million
people when we look
at further into the
future we're expecting
that this will be
22% of the worldwide
population. And when we
look at the breakdown of
65 years and older or
oldest old, we'll see
that the worldwide
population of the oldest
old is expected to
triple. So we're going to
go from 126.5 million
to 446.6 million, which
is an enormous shift. In
the U.S. specifically,
the 65 and over
population is expected
to nearly double by
2050. We're talking
about 48 million to
roughly 80 million people.
When we look at some
of the imagery that's
available to help us
to understand this
concept, if you look
around the world, you'll
see that in 2015, the
population in the United
States and canada was
14 to 20.9 percent
who were in the geriatric
category whereas by
2050 that's expected to
be 21 to 27.9 percent
and you'll notice
that in some countries
like europe for
example that's going to
actually be 28 or higher
in some countries there
is absolutely no
population growth and
their deaths are exceeding
their birth rates.
Here's another
example. This is from
the United Nations
Population Fund.
If you click on
the link in the
reference here at
the bottom, you can
delve deeper into
different countries.
But again, it shows
pretty much the same
thing. And this is
as of 2021 right now.
so what are some of
the general principles
that affect the geriatric
population we're
going to cover those
in the next few slides
but there are four
basic principles the
effects of aging
multiple comorbidities
polypharmacy and disability
or impaired recovery
so aging itself is the
inevitable irreversible
decline that occurs
in all of us in
our organs over time
even in the absence
of poor lifestyle
choices illness or
injury so we're all
going to age regardless
of how healthy we
are now or even later
in life now initially
this is manifested
by a reduced capacity
of organ systems to
maintain homeostasis
in illness and injury.
But later on, this
also affects recovery,
which causes a
cycle of illness
recovery, illness
recovery, and that recovery
becomes more and more
limited each time.
The cardiovascular,
renal, and CNS
systems are especially
vulnerable to the
effects of aging.
Now here we see a model
that describes how
aging leads to changes
in body composition,
energy production
and utilization,
homeostasis, and
neurodegeneration.
These in turn
lead to frailty.
So if you start
here, right, we're
the aging person
and we have all of
these things happening
in us right now.
Eventually they lead
to frailty. Now frailty
in turn contributes
to the continuance
of these domains, but
it also then leads to
these geriatric
syndromes that are here.
And so these geriatric
syndromes impact
the patient's response
to disease and illness,
as well as healing
and recovering from
it. And those are
anorexia or malnutrition,
gait or disorders or
falls, disability,
deceased
susceptibility or
comorbidity, urinary
incontinence,
decubitus ulcer,
sleep disorders,
delirium and
cognitive impairment.
You can see from
this diagram
some of the
physiologic changes
that occur in the
aging patient.
Down across the x
-axis here, you'll
see that we're
starting here at
30 years of age
and going up to 90.
And then you can see
how much on the y-axis,
how much of that organ
system or physiologic
function is remaining
as we age. And so
as you go across,
you can see there's a
progressive decline
some of them are steeper
than others in things
like nerve conduction
velocity basal metabolic
rates cardiac function
renal function and
respiratory function
geriatric patients
often have multiple
concomitant illnesses
this is one of
the other principles
of aging and these
will interact with
one another to impact
the patient's
physiology how they
present with illness
and recovery. And
symptoms of disease
that are often present
and shows up in patients
will often affect
the most compromised
organ system. So the
typical presentation
for hypo or
hyperthyroidism, for
example, in someone who's 30
years old may not be
what you see in someone
who's geriatric. So
for hyperthyroidism,
if they have heart
disease of any kind,
then hyperthyroidism
may just show
up in this patient as
atrial fibrillation
and not your
typical symptoms.
Or on the opposite
side, hypothyroidism
in a patient who
has like really
poorly controlled
diabetes or has
had diabetes for many
years, they might
present with some
simple symptoms
such as constipation
or ***** impaction,
but they're not
presenting with
the other symptoms
of hypothyroidism.
So these are, this
is really important
when you're considering
your patient who's
in front of you and what
kind of comorbidities
do they have.
What else are they
suffering from? And if
there's disease that's
presenting in that
system or that it's
worsened suddenly,
then that may be a sign
that there's something
else happening.
okay another principle
is polypharmacy now
a few things to understand
about pharmaceuticals
right you've
already learned some
of this is that aging
as well as some of
our comorbidities
will affect the drug's
absorption volume of
distribution how it binds
to proteins and how
we eliminate it now
any changes in our
ability to do any of that
obviously lead to
fluctuations in therapeutic
drug levels and an
increased risk of
under or overdosing
a patient. So when we
think about the geriatric
patient who's on
multiple medications,
these effects of
aging on the body's ability
to clear medications
or absorb them or
bind them can lead
to signs or symptoms of
things like endocrine
disease or they may
mask signs or symptoms
of things like
endocrine disease or in
any other system.
So just keep that in
mind when you're
prescribing medications and
also when you're
considering how the patient
is presenting with
a specific illness.
We get down to our
fourth principle now,
which is disability
and impaired recovery.
Now, disability in
the geriatric patient
is always multifactorial.
They have a
variety of different
things that have led to
this or that are
compounding everything.
So, lower body fat
composition, reduced
lean body mass, reduced
energy efficiency,
poor nutritional
intake sometimes,
neurologic dysfunction,
cognitive impairment,
and there's a variety
of other things
that can contribute.
Now, disability occurs
late in the process
after we've expended all
of our reserves and our
ability to compensate
has been exhausted.
So you can be sick
for quite a while before
suddenly everything
starts to have
considerable dysfunction.
Now, when we also think
about not only just
the development of
disease, but also then
the recovery from it, so
disability may contribute
to the development
or progression of
disease. But then we
also have to recover from
it. And so if we have all
of these multifactorial
things contributing
to our disability,
we know that they'll
also contribute to
our ability to recover
and to compensate for
what's happening when
we are ill or injured.
And that sets up a
vicious cycle of illness
injury, illness injury,
recovery, but sometimes
or oftentimes the
recovery is never back
to the former baseline
that they were at.
Okay, so here's an
example of aging,
physiologic changes to
the endocrine system.
you can see there's
a variety of things
that are lost over
time or a variety
of things that develop
over time sorry
about that that
was the printer
decided to go
off I apologize
all right so there
are other physical and
physiologic changes
that occur and we're
going to cover these
over the next two
slides there is an
entire table in Bates
which is very helpful
that lists a lot more
than this, but I'm
going to cover some
main points that I'd
like you to remember.
So systolic blood
pressure rises as we age,
the aorta and arteries
stiffen and become
atherosclerotic, and
there is a decline in
cardiac pacemaker
cells that affects our
maximal heart rate and
our ability to respond
to exercise and
stress. Cardiac output
decreases and valvular
leaflet changes or
stiffening can occur
as we age. And these
changes can lead to
things like orthostatic
hypotension or to
the development of
arrhythmias or cardiac
murmurs like aortic stenosis
or mitral recurgitation
murmurs. Changes
to ventricular
compliance and reductions
in ventricular filling
can lead to a fourth
heart sound, which
is normal in an older
adult. So if you hear
that fourth heart
sound, that's generally
normal for that
patient. The temperature
regulation changes so
that the aging patient
is more likely to
have hypothermia.
They're more sensitive to
temperature fluctuations,
especially to the
cold, or they may not
mount a fever like
you would normally
expect during illness.
Visual acuity
decreases due to the
development of cataracts,
glaucoma, or macular
degeneration, or
from the effects of
illnesses like diabetes
or hypertension,
or from the simple
development of
presbyopia, the need
for reading glasses.
These changes will
and can affect
the patient's
quality of life and
also make the
patient increasingly
susceptible to
falls and injuries.
Hearing decreases
usually after the age
of 50, which can
affect communication
and quality of life.
Visual and hearing
deficits and mobility
problems can socially
isolate someone
quite significantly.
now for oral changes
there is decreased
saliva production
which affects
the oral health
of the patient
leading to things like
increased cavities
gum disease
periodontal disease
teeth can wear down
fall out or become
abraded over time based
on our diet and so the
loss of dental health
affects things like
feeding communication
our appearance which
can affect our mental
health in the respiratory
system we lose lung
capacity our chest
wall becomes stiffer
and harder to move,
diaphragmatic strength
decreases, respiratory
muscles weaken, lungs
lose some of their
elastic recoil, and
the surface area for
gas exchange shrinks.
And there can be
changes in the thoracic
spine, which lead to
increased kyphosis,
which can also affect
our respiratory ability.
Now, all of these
combine to leading to
a less effective cough
mechanism and increasing
our predisposition
or our risk for
developing atelectasis
and pneumonia with
respiratory conditions.
The breasts in particular
in women tend to
become smaller, more
flaccid and pendulous,
and the glandular
tissue atrophies so that
things like ducts
become more palpable
as ropey or stringy
strands. In males, they
may develop gynecomastia
or an increased
breast fullness, especially
if they've developed
obesity or had some
hormonal changes.
abdominal muscles
tend to weaken the fat
may accumulate in
lower abdomen and the
hips so that our
appearance changes even
if our weight hasn't
and aging can blunt
some of the symptoms
of gi disease so they
might have less pain
guarding or rebound
tenderness um it
may be completely
diminished or absent
and remember fever is
less pronounced so if
there's anything going
on in the GI system
and they're afebrile.
Don't rule out an
infectious process.
For the *******
urinary system,
****** interest appears
to remain intact,
but the frequency of
*********** will decrease.
***** hair decreases
and becomes gray in
color. In males, decreased
testosterone levels
lead to decreases
in things like *****
size. The ********* drop
lower in the *******
and erections also
decrease the incidence
of prostatic hypertrophy
and prostate cancer
will increase and in
women menses and in
menopause begins and
menopause leads to a
variety of symptoms
including hot flashes mood
swings and vaginal
dryness amongst others the
***** and ********
will become smaller the
vagina shortens and
the vaginal mucosa
atrophies and becomes
thinner these changes lead
to increased pain
with *********** which
can make it very
uncomfortable and affect the
patient's quality
of life or how they
perceive themselves the
suspensory ligaments of
the adnexa uterus and
bladder may also relax
which can contribute
to urinary incontinence
and some other things
that can contribute
to urinary incontinence
include decreased
innervation and
contractility of the bladder
muscles loss of bladder
capacity urinary
flow rate and the ability
to inhibit avoiding
incontinence in general
is very socially
isolating for
patients, and so
addressing it with
them is important and
helping them to find
ways to manage it.
In the MSK system,
there is a loss
of bone with increased
development of
osteoporosis and
increased risk for
fractures, as well
as loss of height
and the development
of kyphosis.
There is a 30 to 50
percent decline in
muscle mass and ligaments,
lose some of their
tensile strength,
and we also move and
react with less speed
and agility as we age.
Osteoarthritis
affects our range
of motion and can
lead to chronic
pain and issues
with mobility.
And tremors and other
movement disorders
can also affect our
mobility and function.
Now when we get down
to the nervous system,
we know that aging
and chronic disease
states contribute
to neurodegeneration
which affects things
like memory strength
reflexes balance
coordination and these in
turn lead to effects
on the quality of
life mood and recovery
from illness as well
all right so we're
next we're going to
cover the care of the
geriatric patient and
this necessitates
some changes and
adaptations to our
usual patterns of seeing
adult patients. Most
of these adaptations
are to accommodate the
needs of the patient
and also cover topics
that we might not
be discussing with
our younger patients.
Elements that we want
you to pay attention
to are health
history, physical
exam, assessment of
functional status,
assessment of goals and
of care and prognosis,
access to care,
in particular a
team-based approach,
and long-term planning,
which includes things
like palliative
care and hospice
when necessary. So
let's talk about
the approach to the
geriatric patient and
some of the things that
will impact or
require adaptation. So
the office setting
in particular, the
patient's first
interaction with you and
with your staff is when
they walk into your
office. And so it's
beneficial to the
patient to arrange it
to meet their needs.
And so things like
having moderate
temperatures, not too
cool or not too warm,
ensuring that
there is brighter
lighting,
especially because
eyesight has
diminished as we age.
Removing any obstacles
from hallways,
entrances, exam rooms, and
making sure that things
are generally less
cluttered can make
it easier for the person
who needs a mobility
aid, like a walker or
a cane or a wheelchair,
or even has difficulty
with gait to
get around and into and
out of spaces in the
office having quiet
exam rooms is also
important they should be
free from distractions
especially noise so
that the person can
concentrate and stay
focused and hear what's
happening chairs with
higher seating make
it easier to get in
and out of for patients
who are geriatric
and having stools
available in the examination
room with a handrail
so the patient can
get on and off the
exam table will facilitate
the physical exam
Now, in terms of
communication,
there are a variety of
things that you can do.
Have forms with larger
fonts and to make
it easier for them
to see and complete,
but also mail or email
them earlier so that
they can complete them
without that feeling
of, I'm being rushed
or causing them
stress to complete
the forms immediately.
It's important to ask
them to bring family
or friends with them
to the appointments to
ensure that the care
plans are understood
and that the action
is any action that's
needed is taken on any
orders that are given
on a care plan and
this is especially true
on patients who have
difficulty with communication
language barriers
or have cognitive
deficits now having
someone available on
staff to help patients
with technology that
might be used in our
offices today things like
sign-in kiosks patient
portals will be
very helpful them as well
to help continue that
flow of communication
now when they're in
their space with you
ask the patient to
turn on their hearing
aids put on their glasses
and put in their dentures
all are essential
they should be able
to see you hear you
and be able to speak
clearly so that
communication is facilitated
as much as possible
and you want as
the provider you
want to face the
patient directly
and sit at
their eye level
Finally, you want
to have some clear
HIPAA documents that
cover who can and cannot
receive information
on this patient.
Geriatric patients
often have very specific
people that they
want involved in
their care, but
sometimes there's an
assumption that you'll
just tell everyone.
You'll tell their
children, you'll tell
their family members.
And so for you,
knowing who is the
point person or who
you can communicate
with or who can assist
you when necessary
is very important.
Now, make sure that
the patient and family
caregiver always have
a clear list of current
medications with dose,
route, frequency,
and why the medication
is taken as well.
And additionally, make
sure that anything
you give the patient
that is educational
isn't a large
enough font or in
their preferred language
so that they can
read it independently.
independently.
Time-wise you want to
make sure that your
appointments have enough
time to allow you to
do your tasks and
allow the patient and
their family or
caregivers to ask you any
questions that they
might have but also allow
them to tell you some of
their stories. Sometimes
the stories for
geriatric patients can
begin a specific point
and they spread out
over time and having
that picture is often
helpful for us. You
want to adjust your pace
so that you're not
speaking too rapidly or
that you're making the
patient feel rushed.
And if necessary or
when necessary, consider
scheduling follow
-up appointments or
double appointments
to allow time for
everything that needs
to be covered. It will
also be helpful to the
patient who, especially
as they get older
and older, because
fatigue is a consideration
here as well.
And finally, records.
The geriatric patient
often has a variety
of specialists that
are involved in their
care. So getting these
consultation reports is
sometimes a challenge,
but keeping your
records up to date as
much as possible
means that you have a
comprehensive picture
of what is happening
when the patient is
outside of your care. Now
this also means that
you want to document
conversations with any
specialists or vendors
who provide special
services like delivering
adult diapers or
providing wheelchairs,
insurance companies,
and with the patient,
family, and caregivers.
You also want to
have updated files um
on record for advanced
directives so things
like healthcare
proxies living wills
dnr dni and this because
this will ensure that
we are complying with
our patients wishes
and their care
instructions all right
so let's get down to the
history and physical
portion for history
taking you want to use
as many resources of
information as possible
For one, this prevents
repetition of
material. It reinforces
what the patient is
telling you and validates
it, and it also
provides a more accurate
picture of their current
status and needs.
So sources that
are available to
us include things
like family members,
caregivers, home
health aides,
other specialists
or physicians,
hospital discharge
records, and previous
medical records. So
there's a little bit of
detective work sometimes
that's necessary.
You want to ask direct
questions and you
want to listen carefully
throughout this
whole process. And you
want to keep in mind
the patient experience
and their perspective.
And the patient is the
one who's experienced
the illness or the
disease state or
decline. And so you
want to always remember
that, that when you're
getting their history
and performing their
physical, that you're
keeping them at the
forefront of this.
you want to ask thorough
histories complete
review of systems
when it's necessary
and keep and also
remember that sometimes
patients under report
symptoms because
their fear of they
have a fear of losing
independence or a fear
of being diagnosed
with an illness like
a malignancy and they
just you know they're
at the point where
they're like I don't
really want to know
sometimes they have
common symptoms or signs
but they they think
they're part of like
normal aging like joint
pain, back pain, memory
deficits. But those
symptoms or signs might
be masking other
underlying diseases that
are readily treatable
or that we can help
them with. And so a
review of systems is often
the place where we
gather what's happening.
Now, a patient may have
cognitive impairment
and may not provide
an accurate timeline
or description of what
they're feeling our
experience because
they've forgotten and that
can happen, right? So
this is where family
and caregivers can
really help fill in the
blanks for us or explain
what they're observing
in the patient from
their usual baseline.
And finally, you
want to consider
the patient's perspective
of this shift
in their life.
Oftentimes what
they're looking at now
is not so much as
how many years have
I lived, but more so
how many more years
do I have left? What
will those years
look like? How can
I stay independent,
live in my own home?
Who can help me?
You know, will there
be any suffering? So
those are things that
are in their perspective
and what might be
contributing to how they
interact with you. So
while it's important
to have the family and
caregivers involved,
we're still responsible
to the patient for
their wishes. So we
want to keep them
involved in the decision
-making process, of
course, barring anything
that might be diminishing
their capacity to
make those decisions.
And finally, we
want to think about
cultural dimensions.
There's table 27.2
in Bates in chapter
27 is an excellent,
has a list of
excellent questions to
ask. And so I want
you to have a look
at that so that you
have an idea of how
you might formulate
those questions.
But cultural dimensions
are important in
the care of the geriatric
patients. We don't
want to make assumptions
or miss key points
about how the patient
views themselves,
their condition, their
prognosis. We want
to make sure that we
listen to what they're
expressing and that
we're exploring their
comments when we think
that they're not clear
or that something
might sound confusing.
And so for an example
of something that
I've heard from a
geriatric patient living
with chronic pain was,
I don't want to live
with this anymore.
Now, that expression
could mean like, you know,
the pain's unbearable,
find a way to help
me minimize it. But
that expression could
also mean that they're
depressed and they're
considering suicide.
So if you ever hear
something like this,
you want to explore
that, you want to ask
more questions and
get more information.
And finally,
consideration of diversity
in our aging population
in the United
States and in other
countries around
the world that reflects
this demographic
shift that we've
talked about earlier.
And this demographic
shift, you know, has
happened because of
immigration wars, conflicts,
but also because of
socioeconomic factors
like poverty, discrimination,
climate change,
education, and a
variety of other things.
Culture shapes our
beliefs about aging,
illness, death, disease,
mental health, our
choices in our doctors
and our healers, and
about the healthcare
care system in general.
So it's important to
try to understand your
patient's cultural
norms and to adjust your
care plans to reflect
those whenever necessary.
Let patients establish
their cultural
identity with you. Explore
where they're from.
What are their cultural
explanations about
almost dying or aging?
And what are factors
that impact level of
function and their
environment? And what is
the expectation of you
as their clinician and
in this relationship
that you're developing
or have developed.
And when we think
about how culture
impacts this, this
becomes especially
important in
discussions about end
-of-life care and
decision-making. All
right, so in the history,
when you're gathering
that, there's areas
that might require
additional exploration
or getting more
information from your
patient, and that includes
finding out if there
any impairments in
their daily living or
in their instrumental
activities of daily living
medication management
and side effects
so you want to know
like how are they
getting their medications
who's dispensing it for
them if they can't do
it themselves who picks
up refills and are
they having any side
effects and also are
they taking their
medications as prescribed
smoking obviously alcohol
use drug use those
are things that we
would also explore But
in particular, the
disease burden that
they contribute to in
the geriatric patient
is important to make
sure that you have
accurate information
about how much, how often,
when was the last
time they used any of
these products, have
they ever had any issues
with *****, or are they
considering quitting
if they are using
something regularly.
nutrition also do they
have access to food
so important to know
about sometimes we
don't consider the
availability of food products
to the person we
only think about like
what are they eating
and so having access
to food or and to food
that is healthy is
also a special area of
concern. Pain, chronic
pain, acute pain,
important to explore
and see if it is an
indicator of not only
just a current issue,
but also possibly
contributing to other
problems in a person's
life like isolation,
mobility, or increasing
their risk for *****
of pain medications.
Cognitive
impairment impacts
the patient's
life from A to Z.
You know, this is
everything. It's how
they interact with
family, friends,
their environment,
social environment,
health care, whether
they're taking care
of themselves or
taking medications,
even eating or
remembering to cook meals.
You know,
so knowing whether
your patient has
a cognitive impairment
is essential.
Urinary incontinence
can also
contribute to
social isolation.
Isolation can
also be a sign of
other illnesses
that are happening
or medication
side effects.
And finally, falls.
Falls are a huge
contributor to
patients' morbidity and
mortality, especially
as we get older. So
when we talk about the
concept of activities
of daily living
versus instrumental
activities of daily
living, we want to
ask a few basic
questions, and they
give us an idea of
whether the person is
independent and functional
at their optimal
level. So ADLs, you
want to ask your
patient if they can
perform six basic
self-care abilities,
bathing, dressing,
toileting,
transferring,
continence, and feeding.
For IADLs, you want
to ask about eight
functions, And that's
the use of a telephone,
shopping, preparing
food, housekeeping,
laundry,
transportation,
taking medication, and
managing money
or finances.
And it's really
important to know
whether the person is
independent and can
manage these 14
items on their own
without any difficulty
or if they need
assistance from
someone for any reason.
Once you have the
answers to all of these,
it gives you a
clearer sense of the
person's ability, how
well they're functioning
at this current
level that they're
at, whether there's
been any changes in
the level of function.
It also helps you
to make decisions about
additional services
that they might need,
things like home
care, physical
therapy, mobility aids,
adult diapers, social
services like Meals
on Wheels for nutrition
or transportation
to and from medical
visits. or if someone
needs to just step in
and assist the patient
because they can no
longer manage or perform
these actions on their
own and not having
someone to assist them
will be detrimental
to the patient and
to their health there
are things that we
take into consideration
when we're taking a
patient's history and
also making clinical
decisions at the end
of that visit one of
those is using the
beers criteria to help
make decisions about
what medications a
patient should continue
and this is called
the beers criteria for
potentially inappropriate
medication use
in older adults it's a
list of approximately
100 medications or
medication classes that
is published by the
american geriatric
society approximately
every three years the
last publication was
in 2023 and you can
see the link down
here at the bottom of
this slide if you're
interested in looking
at what's posted. This
acts as a guide for
healthcare providers to
make safe prescribing
decisions for their
geriatric patients
and there are five
different sections that
it covers medications
that should be avoided
in patients who are
of geriatric age
and who are also not in
hospice or palliative
care settings,
medications to avoid in
patients with certain
health conditions or
avoid those that
cause certain drug
interactions that could
be potentially harmful,
limiting doses or
avoiding medications due
to their effects on
kidney function, and
also medications with
potential side effects
whose risks clearly
outweigh any benefits.
One of the caveats to
the Beers criteria to
remember is that it
is not specific to one
person. It is a
guideline. So it's trying
to provide guidance
for a broad group of
people. And because of
this, it doesn't take
into consideration
a patient's specific
overall health, any
underlying medical conditions
or situations that
might make the provider
pick a medication
that is on this list.
So we consider
it as a tool to
use, but it doesn't
make the final
decision on behalf
of a provider.
So one of the important
things to do is
when we are documenting
our clinical
decisions is that
we also document why
a specific medication
was chosen despite
meeting some of
these criteria from
BEERS so that any
others will understand
how the medication
was chosen and why.
Additionally, at every
follow-up visit, we
continue to revisit
that medication list and
continue to take this
into consideration.
And one thing we
should always ask at
follow-up visits
are asking about
side effects as well
as the efficacy of
the medication that
was prescribed.
And this will help
us to make a final
determination of
whether we continue
this medication
or if we stop it
or change it to
something different.
So we're going to
talk about screening
tools here as part
of your history and
physical exam of the
geriatric patient.
It's really important
that you use
validated tools and
screening tests. And here
I've put up a list
of common examples.
There are a greater
variety than this.
You can certainly
refer to Bates or any
geriatric textbook
for more. But these
are common ones that
are used. And these
screening tools have
been validated through
testing and are
proven to be useful
for the purposes that
they're intended.
So an important note
is that you must
use the test as it's
described. So make
sure that you follow
all the instructions
and that you score
as it's written
because that's how the
test was validated.
And there are some
minor cases where
training might be
required to ensure that
you're doing this
evaluation reliably.
So beyond helping us
to get a sense of what
our patient's function
is, they help us
to gather information
in an organized fashion
and help us to make
clinical decisions.
And they can also
be used to track
progression of illness
or disease. So if
you do these multiple
times, you can
see whether there's
change happening,
whether for the
better or the worse.
Now, when you add
in all the questions
that you ask about
ADLs and IADLs, along
with these screening
tools, you get
a very good sense of
the baseline function
of your patient.
And so if you need
to step in and make
any interventions,
then you can do so
knowing that you have the
most appropriate
information available for
a patient. Oftentimes
insurance companies
also require this
information in order to
authorize dispensing
things like wheelchairs
or commodes or hospital
beds to a patient.
And then finally,
you can also identify
any geriatric
syndromes that might be
present and then
help to optimize the
patient's care and
make sure that you have
everybody on your
team that you might
need to help you care
for your patient.
So I'm going to
share two examples of
commonly used screening
tests or tools.
And so here's the 10
-minute geriatric screener.
This is taken directly
from the example
in Bates, if you want
to refer there as
well. But these are
the parts that are
covered, cognitive,
psychosocial, and physical
function including
vision, hearing, and
urinary continence
as well. It gives you
a very good sense
of how the patient's
doing and obviously
when you go down to
physical disability you
can see that some of
the questions go along
with IADLs or ADLs.
Another validated
screening test for memory
disorders, there
are three that I'm
going to touch upon.
We're going to start
with the New Mental
Status Exam or the
MMSC developed by
Fulstein and Fulstein in
1975 and has been
validated multiple
times in English as
well as several other
languages. It's an 11
-question measure. It
tests five areas of
cognitive function,
orientation, registration,
attention, and
calculation, recall,
and language. It takes
about 5 to 10 minutes
to administer by a
trained provider and
the maximum score is
out of 30 points a
score of 23 or lower is
indicative of cognitive
impairment and
obviously the lower the
score the greater the
cognitive impairment
this test is very
effective at helping to
differentiate patients
with cognitive
impairment from those
without cognitive
impairment and one of its
benefits is that it
detects mild cognitive
impairment very well
some of its limitations
are that it relies
heavily on speaking
reading and writing
and so any patients who
are hearing or visually
impaired or have low
English proficiency or
any other communication
disorders may
perform poorly even
though they are cognitively
cognitively intact
sorry about that
performance can also be
affected by things
like fatigue, lack of
sleep, and anything
that alters your mental
function such as
substance use or *****.
Moving on to the
next slide, you can
see here an example
of this examination.
This is all of the
items. So for example,
for orientation,
you would ask all of
these things here. What
is the year, season,
date, day, and month?
And this would be
scored out of
five points. And
you would go down
through all of
these different
steps, ending with
having the patient
copy the design
that is shown
here. And then
you would total
up your score. The
next one is called the
MOCA, or the Montreal
Cognitive Assessment.
It's a rapid screening
instrument also
for mild cognitive
dysfunction it has eight
different cognitive
domains attention and
concentration executive
functions memory
language this visual
construction skills
conceptual thinking
calculations and orientation
it's available in
approximately 100
languages you do have to
go through training in
order to know how to
administer this
effectively and it takes
approximately one hour
to administer It's
been validated multiple
times for patients
between the ages of 55
and 85 years old, and
there are a variety
of different versions
to meet the needs of
different patients.
For example, there's a
telephone-only version.
There's a version
for patients who are
blind. There's a hearing
-impaired version.
If you'd like to
see more information
about this
examination, you can
look at the website
posted here.
and here is what the
Montreal cognitive
assessment score sheet
would look like and
finally we have the
mini cog the mini cog
is also a rapid screening
instrument it's for
cognitive dysfunction
however it is not
recommended to screen
for mild cognitive
impairment this is
better at picking up more
advanced cognitive
dysfunction it has three
items recall tests for
memory so you'll see
that on the next page
and a simply scored clock
drawing test it's also
available in multiple
languages it takes
about three minutes
to administer so it
functions very well for
visits with your patient
and it is encouraged
to be used by Medicare
for the annual
geriatric wellness exam
it's validated multiple
times for patients
between the ages of 55
to 85 years old also
there is an online
version so if you can't
see your patient face
-to-face you can do it
online with them or
they can do it independently
and if you want
more information this is
one of the the website
where you can find
more information about
it and this is what
the score sheet would
look like so the first
part of that recall
is you go through one
of these lists of words
and you have the
patient listen and then
you repeat then you
have your clock drawing
in between there and
this is the circle here
for the clock drawing
and then you do the
recall and then you
tally up everything and
based on that a
determination is made and
then here's one for
mobility it's called
the time to get up and
go test when you're
in DPR lab you'll be
there's gonna be an
opportunity for you
to see what that looks
like but basically
what you want to do is
have your patient wear
their regular footwear
and if they need any
mobility device or
assisted device like a
walker or a cane that
they have it with
them. You're going to
sit them back in an
armless chair and you're
going to instruct
your patient to get up
from this armless chair.
When they hear the
word go, they're going
to walk three meters
in a straight line
as best as they can,
turn around, walk
back to the chair and
sit down. On your part,
you're going to observe
the patient for any
instability, difficulty
with gait or you
know stride length
etc you're also going
to be timing them with
this test now if they
can do all the steps
1 through 5 in less
than 10 seconds that's
considered a normal
test and if it's
abnormal if it's greater
than 20 seconds and
this is a good way to
screen for fall risk
Okay, so we're going to
touch on the physical
examination here.
You already know how
to perform the majority
of the physical
exams necessary, so I'm
not going to revisit
those, but I am
going to talk about
what's important for
the geriatric patient.
So one of the things
with physical exams,
obviously, is your
vitals. And so when
you're paying attention
to your vitals,
you want to pay attention
to the norms and
the patterns that
your patient has. So
you're not just going
to look at today's
vitals, you're going
to compare it to past
vitals. And any
deviation from those
norms or from those
patterns is an indicator
of illness, injury,
or disease state.
And in particular,
changes to weight
can be a really
good indicator that
something's going on
with your patient.
A sudden weight
gain or sudden
weight loss are
clear indicators
that something's
happening.
And so you really want
to look at not just
today's but past
vitals as well. Okay.
When necessary, perform
orthostatic measurements
of blood pressure
and heart rate,
especially if a patient
complains of things
like weakness, dizziness,
lightheadedness,
syncope, or that
they're having visual
deficits or changes
whenever they
stand up or have
postural changes.
Your general survey,
this is you observing
your patient coming into
the space that you're
in, your office or
the examination room.
And it's really important
to pay attention
into their mental status,
to their appearance,
like what's their
grooming like, the
cleanliness of their
clothing, what do their shoes
look like, and their
mobility. How do they
go into the room? Do
they need a mobility
or assistive device?
Do they need someone to
help them get onto
examination tables? Can
they do it independently?
That's going to give
you a lot of good
information on the person's
ability to just, one,
that they're caring
for themselves and to
that they can move.
And now when we talk
about performing
a physical exam,
obviously we take
a systems approach,
head to toe,
you know, assessing
or paying special
attention to
those areas where
the patient might
have a complaint.
But it's also
important to maintain
your patient's
modesty and respect
any cultural norms
that they have.
Remember, you want to
remove clothing and
evaluate directly on
skin to minimize the
risk that you're missing
a sign of illness
and also signs of
injury or ***** or
maltreatment you want
to provide your patient
with a gown and a drape
and ask the patient
before you even physical
begin the physical
exam you want to ask
the patient if it's
okay if any family
members or caregivers
stay in the room
sometimes they don't want
them present and they
may ask that they not
be allowed or ask
them to step out Okay.
For the SOAP note and
for documentation,
you're going to be as
descriptive and detailed
as possible. When
necessary, use the
patient's own words,
especially if it's important
to highlight a particular
point or explain
something. And you
want to share your
progress note with
other members of your
healthcare team. So if
there's a patient navigator
or a specialist who's
involved in their
care, you want them
to be aware of what
happened during this
visit so that they also
have updated information
and so it's important
to include a plan of
care for any chronic
or acute disease
state so that everyone
can see like what were
the goals for this
what's the treatment
plan what kind of
medications are we giving
or diagnose diagnostics
or were there referrals
to other caregivers
or members of the
health care team and
finally let's talk about
preventive care and
health promotion in
the geriatric patient
so as more adults live
to an older age in
particular those that
are 80 years old and
older. The decision
about when to screen for
things like cancer,
for example, becomes
more complex and requires
a discussion about
the limitations that
are available for these
screenings in this
age group, treatment,
and the effects on
quality of life if a
disease is found. The
decision to screen should
also include things
like the patient's
level of health and
function, comorbidities,
prognosis, and expectations
of the patient.
Age should never
be the only factor
that's considered.
You shouldn't
just go, well,
you're 85, we're
going to stop
screening you, right?
You should take into
consideration all
of these things. Now,
there are screening
guidelines
available for these
things, so use them
wherever appropriate
to help educate your
patient, but also
to have this
conversation with them.
Now other things to
screen for are found in
the 10-minute geriatric
screener that we
looked at earlier. These
require less complex
conversations, you
know, vision, hearing,
falls, mobility, but
they should be completed
and the patient
should be informed of
important findings and
also what is the plan
to address any deficits
that are observed.
Exercise and physical
activity, really
important for
maintaining mobility
and independence,
reducing falls and
pain, and keeping
the person engaged
in activities outside
of the home thereby
reducing social isolation
this tends to happen
a lot if i can't
get around because i'm
physically unable to
patient tends to stay
home tends to not
be involved or the
family sometimes
just is unable to come
to the patient and
therefore they're
not really engaged
or involved in
which leads to other
factors like depression
for example and
greater effects on
cognition and mobility
so um you know
recommendations for this
age group are that
they do aerobic
activity and also
muscle strength training
training for major
muscle groups so
that they can maintain
their mobility
Now, obviously, you'd
adapt any exercise
recommendations to
the person's current
ability, like if they
need a cane or a walker
to stand and walk
properly, then maybe doing
exercises in a chair
is better for them
than trying to stand
and do the exercises.
But whenever necessary,
you can involve
a physical therapist
or a physiatrist in
the care of the
patient to address any
issues with exercise
or physical activity
and help put together
a plan that's
appropriate to them and
that's safe for them.
Household safety also
very important for
your patient's health
and well-being and it's
often overlooked as
we age within our own
homes right but it's
essential that we
prevent injury and so
some basic things that
can be done in and
around the home like
garages and gardens you
want to ensure appropriate
lighting you want to
get rid of furniture
that's too low or too
high to get in and
out of so if you need
a stool to get into
bed, that's not safe
for you. If you sit
in a chair and you
can't get out of it,
that's not safe for
you. You want to install
handrails in both
directions on staircases.
Most staircases have
only one unidirectional
handrail, so you want
one on each side.
You want to remove
clutter and ensure
clear paths from
one room to another.
Nothing should
be in the way of
somebody safely
walking from like a
kitchen to a bathroom
or to a bedroom
and you want to
ensure easy access to
telephones to call
for help so things you
can do is move them
to a low-lying table
or close to the sofa
or close to whatever
area where there's
a risk for a fall
so the patient can
call for help or
you can provide a
mobile phone or get a
clinical alert device
that can call for
help in the event
that the person falls.
You want to instruct
your patients
to always wear
well-fitting shoes
in and outside of
the home, right?
So loose slippers,
for example,
not safe.
And also consider
the safety of
laces for your
patient, especially
if they have
shuffling gates.
So you may want
to just remove
laces entirely and
just use Velcro.
And then keep commonly
used items within
reach to minimize the
need to stand on a step
stool or a ladder
install grab bars in the
tub and shower and
use a shower chair if
necessary if there's
issues with balance or
standing you also want
to remove any cords
that could be a tripping
hazard and secure
all firearms to keep
everyone safe and finally
you want to have a
plan in place of a
system where someone
checks on the patient on
a daily basis at least
once or if needed
multiple times throughout
the day to ensure
that they are safe
and if you don't hear
from them immediately
or they don't respond
within the time frame
that you're used to
that you can call for
help and get them help
and finally elder *****
and mistreatment is
not always reported
because of the fear of
reprisal or increased
*****. About 90% of
the time, it is a family
member or a caregiver
who perpetrates
the *****, and so
they're often afraid
to say anything because
they don't know what
the outcomes will be for
them. And although
the USPSTF has noted
that there is no valid
or reliable screening
tool for elder *****,
it is still important
to ask about it. So
ask your patient if
they are being
abused, neglected, and
exploited, or feel like
they've been abandoned.
You know,
a simple question is
anyone hurting you or
abusing you but also
asking about restriction
to access to things
like money or food pay
attention to the
history that they're
providing you how they
say things what they say
and also how they
interact with any family
or caregivers that are
present at the visit
additionally you also
want to pay attention
to your physical exam
for signs that could
be indicative of
***** or mistreatment.
Self-neglect is also
something that's important
to pay attention to,
and this is a patient
who is a threat to
themselves because
they're not taking care
of themselves. So they
may not be following
your care plan, may
not be taking their
medications, may be
ignoring their own health
for whatever reason.
So if there's any
suspicion on your part
of any of these
things happening,
including self-neglect,
the patient should
be reported to adult
protective services
as soon as you're
aware of it or
consider it so that
they can step in and
help the patient as
much as possible.
Okay.
And finally, immunizations.
Geriatric patients
should receive
immunizations like flu,
DTaP or an updated
tetanus toxoid,
varicella,
shingles or zoster
vaccine, pneumococcal,
and now during
this time, the
COVID-19 vaccine.
The complications of
fractures related to
osteoporosis are often
severe and can include
increased mortality,
increased morbidity
such as loss of
mobility, increased pain,
loss of independence,
increased risk for
future fractures,
and an increased risk
of having to be
transferred to a nursing
home or needing additional
help. So this is
why it's very
important to screen for
osteoporosis and determine
fracture risks using
bone density testing
and the FRAX score.
So bone density
testing is done
by x-ray. It's
imaging used to screen
for osteoporosis,
and it can
also help determine
fracture risk.
The x-rays are
usually two different
energies. That's
why it's called
a DEXA, a dual X
-ray absorptometry.
And these are just the
X-ray beams that are
passed through
specific bones, such as
the hip, the lumbar
spine, or the radius in
the wrist. The bone
mineral density is
calculated for each bone
after the person has
gotten this X-ray, and
then it's converted
into values that are
related to the average
female or male peak
bone mass or to the
bone mass relative
to the patient's age.
And these are called
T-scores and Z-scores.
T-scores and Z-score
values are usually based
on women, although
in some places there
is sufficient male data
to base it on males.
When that male data
is not available, we
use the same cutoffs
for men and women.
Now, the World Health
Organization and
the International
Society for Clinical
Densitometry have
defined diagnostic
criteria for low bone
mass namely osteopenia
and osteoporosis
based on the DEXA scan
compared with the
reference population
according to the World
Health Organization
osteoporosis is
defined based on the
following of bone
density values a t-score
within one standard
deviation plus or
minus one of the young
adult mean indicates
normal bone density.
A T-score of 1 to
2.5 standard deviations
below the young
adult mean or minus 1
to minus 2.5 standard
deviations indicates
low bone mass or
osteopenia. A T
-score of 2.5 standard
deviations or more below
the young adult mean
indicates the presence
of osteoporosis.
Now We'll cover
a DEXA scan every
other year for women
who are 65 years
and older, and men
who are 70 years
and older, or for
a younger patient
if they have
specific conditions.
Now, while
osteoporosis is
more prevalent in women,
men tend to have a
greater morbidity
related to
osteoporotic fractures.
So, who do we recommend
bone density testing
for? So here's a
list of specific
criteria. There are
others, but these are the
most common ones. Women
65 years or older,
or women who are 50
to 64 with certain
risk factors like
postmenopausal, not taking
estrogen, or someone
who is tall, over 5
'7", or thin, weighing
less than 125 pounds,
for example. Or they
have a personal and
maternal history of
hip fractures, where
they have a personal
history of smoking.
Additionally,
if they are a 70-year
-old man or a male
who is 50 to 69-year
-old with risk factors
like clinical conditions
associated with
bone loss such as
rheumatoid arthritis.
Additionally,
certain medications
can cause accelerated
bone loss or
certain chronic
medical conditions
such as liver disease,
kidney disease,
hyperthyroidism,
type 1 diabetes,
hyperparathyroidism,
hypogonadism,
and vitamin D deficiency,
to name a few.
Additionally, if a
patient's experienced a
fracture after very mild
trauma, it's also an
indication to screen,
or if it's an incidental
finding, for example,
they have back
pain and they get an x
-ray and there you see a
vertebral fracture that
the person was unaware
of, or there are
signs of osteoporosis.
The FRAC score is
called the Fracture Risk
Assessment Tool. It
was developed in 2008
by a team based within
the World Health
Organization who is
collaborating with the
Center for Metabolic
Bone Disease hosted
at the University of
Sheffield in England.
And basically what it
does is it generates
a score that is used
to determine a person's
10-year risk of major
osteoporotic fractures.
And it's calculated
based on 12 factors.
They're all listed
here, age, ***, weight,
height, prior factor,
history, et cetera.
The link on this
slide will take you
to the online
calculator for this so
you can test it
out if you'd like.
There are options.
One of the options is
that you have to have
a T-score, but on the
online calculator,
you can calculate the
risk if the person has
not yet had a bone
density and if you're
trying to determine
who should be treated.
So for patients with
osteopenia based on DEXA
criteria but who do not
have a prior history
of osteoporotic
fractures, we use this
calculator to help
determine the decision for
treatment. In patients
50 years and older
with osteopenia based
on DEXA criteria and who
have a 10-year hip
fracture probability of
3% or higher or a 10
-year major fracture
probability of 20% or
higher using this tool,
then we recommend
treatment for osteopenia.
For patients with a
fragility fracture,
a diagnosis of
osteoporosis based on DEXA
is not needed to
initiate treatment and
you don't need to do
the calculation here.
Right so here's
a summary of
things that
we've discussed.
So it's really important
to not only know
the effects of aging
on the human body,
the presentation
of illness in the
geriatric patient,
but also the geriatric
syndromes and how all
of these interplay
to affect the health
and well-being of
your patient and with
the ultimate goal
is that we keep our
patient independent
and healthy for as
long as they can be.
If you have
any questions,
please shoot me an email.
Thank you for
listening to this
lecture. If you
have any feedback,
please use the
link on this slide.
And here are some of the
references that
were used today.
Thank you for
listening and for
participating.
I hope you have
a great day and
a great week.